In late March, last year, 2016, I became a parent for the first time.
Like so many parents,...
...I wondered how I was going to balance my work with my new role as parent.
And in that moment, I remember that the statistic for the US's policy on maternity leave...
...flashed through my mind.
American women are currently entitled to 12 weeks' unpaid leave.
American men are entitled to nothing.
Somehow, we and every American parent were expected to be "back to normal" in under three months.
Without income?
I remember thinking to myself,...
..."If the practical reality of pregnancy is another mouth to feed in your home,...
...and America is a country where most people are living paycheck to paycheck,...
...how does 12 weeks' unpaid leave economically work?"
The truth is, for too many people, it doesn't.
One in four American women go back to work two weeks after giving birth...
...because they can't afford to take off any more time than that.
That's 25 percent of American women.
Equally disturbing, women who can afford to take a full 12 weeks...
...often don't because it will mean incurring a "motherhood penalty,"...
...meaning they will be perceived as less dedicated to their job...
...and will be passed over for promotions and other career advancement.